et ces femmes elles demandent à pouvoir
subvenir à leurs besoins vitaux et à
ceux de leurs proches et notamment à
protéger leurs enfants ce qu'elle nous
dit c'est qu'elles sont prêtes à tous
les sacrifices et c'est ce qu'elles font
pour protéger leurs enfants puisque
c'est c'est pour leurs enfants qu'elles
poussent la porte du Secours Catholique
et de beaucoup
d'associations solidarité et elles sont
prêtes à manquer des repas voir à plus
pour payer une sortie scolaire à leurs
enfants et et et et les protéger de de
de de toute la violence que que que
représente la
précarité et pour ça ce nous on ce qu'on
ce sur quoi on interpelle c'est
notamment la question de la rémunération
descente des personnes qui sont en
emploi mais pas pas que des personnes
qui sont sans emploi également puisque
une partie d'entre elles on l'a dit
travaill mais une partie d'entre elles
aussi sont assez éloigné du marché de
l'emploi aussi parce que avoir des
enfants c'est compliqué c'est c'est une
un facteur d'éloignement d'un du marché
de l'emploi en tout cas ça peut être
plus difficile de retrouver un emploi de
s'organiser de trouver un mode de G
d'enfants et cetera quand quand on a des
enfants ça peut être plus difficile
d'avoir un temps plein donc on est
plutôt sur du temps partiel donc aussi
des des revenus moins importants les
rémunérations des femmes qui sont
structurellement moins importantes que
celles des hommes euh des métiers qui
sont aussi moins valorisé moins reconnu
elles sont beaucoup dans les métiers du
soin et là aussi on interpelle sur la
question de de de voilà de la
rémunération décente de de des métiers
que qu'occupent ces
femme la question on l'a dit de enfin je
l'ai pas vraiment mentionné mais il y a
la situation administrative des
personnes étrangères mais il y a aussi
la possibilité de leur donner la
possibilité de travailler c'estàd que
les personnes étrangères qu'on rencontre
nous disent qu'elles ne veulent pas
dépendre de prestation sociales elles
veulent pouvoir travailler elles veulent
pouvoir subvenir directement à leur à
leur besoins et au besoins de leur
famille
elle cette question de de se sentir
dépendant d'une administration et d'une
aide sociale et de devoir justifieré de
revenus et cetera c'est quelque chose
qui qui peut être vécu comme quelque
chose d'hum Milant d'infantilisant pour
les personnes elles ont envie d'être
autonomees et ça passe par le la
possibilité de pouvoir travailler